[Music]
hey everyone welcome to another
installment of Harry Potter Theory today
we're going to be discussing plot holes
it shouldn't come as any sort of a
surprise that even within the
captivating Wizarding Universe astute
readers and viewers have stumbled upon
perplexing plot holes and these gaps in
the narrative where certain details seem
to defy logic or leave unanswered
questions have sparked Lively debates
among Harry Potter enthusiasts today
we'll embark on a quest to dissect some
of the most intriguing plot holes that
have left fans scratching their heads
diving into these Mysteries examining
the inconsistencies and seeking to find
plausible explanations or theories that
help to reconcile these discrepancies a
few of the more common plot holes
identified by fans actually have simp
simpler explanations than you may think
anyway I won't Dole any longer let's
dive into it why didn't Voldemort make
his death eers make the unbreakable vow
the unbreakable vow is a magical
contract made between two parties that
utilizes a binding spell it's a
dangerous and Powerful spell that
carries significant risks essentially if
either party breaks the term of The Vow
they instantly die and given how honest
the spell keeps everyone it's
surprisingly un utilized in the Harry
Potter series and one use case in
particular that often jumps to the
Forefront of fans Minds is why didn't
Voldemort to use it on his death heaters
they were his followers his henchmen
they can't think of a better way to keep
your followers loyal than the imminent
threat of death there are a few possible
explanations for this apparent plot hole
but I still think that the vow would
have been a better course of action the
first possibility is that Voldemort
valued fear of loyalty Voldemort was
known for instilling fear in his
followers rather than relying on their
genuine loyalty he may have believed the
threat of punishment or death was enough
to keep his followers in line and that
the unbreakable vow was
unnecessary he also had an exceedingly
large ego which may have caused him to
believe that no one would possibly cross
him he was also extremely powerful and
perhaps overly confident in his magical
abilities he may have believed that he
could control his followers using
legitiment or other similar means and
therefore felt no need to resort to the
unbreakable vow the unbreakable vow
would have kept people like Snape from
becoming double
agents Why did no one notice Peter pigr
on the Marauders map one of the biggest
plot holes in the Harry Potter franchise
revolves around Ron's pet rat scabbers
who was later revealed to be Peter
pettigru Ron slept with scamers every
night and carried him around which
should have been visible on the
Marauders map possessed by Fred and
George
Weasley however the twins never
mentioned to anyone that ROM is sleeping
with a man named Peter some argue that
Fred and George may not have noticed
every name on the map but given their
mischievous nature and love for pranks
it seems likely that they would have
checked on Ron's location enough times
to spot his invisible friend Peter
making this particular Revelation a
glaring inconsistency in the story I'm
sure Peter petre's name wouldn't have
meant much to Fred and George but the
constant close proximity with their
brother should have set off alarm Bells
why even have locks in the Harry Potter
story our protagonists encounter door
locks on a few occasions and while this
may seem like a rather innocuous detail
to dive into I can't help but think
about how usess locks are in the magical
world the main reason for this being
that the unlocking charm alohamora is
Tau to firste Hogwart students if just
about every Witch and Wizard walking
around has the ability to unlock locks
it makes them seem very pointless there
also seem to be a variety of door
unlocking slen unlocking charms present
in the Wizarding World which makes this
doubly confusing Goen cevy is using
muggle technology at Hogwarts in the
Goblet of Fire it is established that
Muckle technology doesn't function at
Hogwarts preventing students from using
phones or email to communicate with
their
parents however bearing that piece of
information in mind it seems puzzling
that Colin Cy's muggle camera appears to
work just fine it is possible that a
professor Enchanted the camera to make
Colin feel more at home and allow him to
capture his Wizarding experiences but
I'm a bit skeptical how did Fred and
George get into the Marauders map the
Marauders map was originally created by
James Potter Sirius Black Remis Lupin
and Peter pettigru during their time at
Hogwarts and since the map's creation it
has changed hands on a few occasions
when Fred and George Weasley began
attending Hogwarts they stole the map
from Argus filch and after getting ample
use of it they passed it on to Harry
Potter while handing the map over they
inform him that the password to activate
it is I solemnly swear that I am up to
no good by tapping the map with a wand
and reciting the password the map
reveals its Secrets including the layout
of Hogwart School of Witchcraft and
Wizardry the location of every person
within the castle and secret pass
messages that can be used to navigate
the school grounds
undetected the issue here is how Fred
and George would have figured out the
map's password as they stole the map
from VCH presumably no one would have
ever told them as things stand there's
no identifiable explanation for how the
pair would have revealed the map's
Secrets or even why it would have stood
out as an item of Interest the trace is
inconsistent after first stepping F into
the World of Magic Harry was repeated ly
cautioned against using magic outside
the premises of the school and before
Muggles The Wizarding world's
concealment depended on this the
ministry of magic attempted to instill
discipline in young witches and wizards
by tracking any use of magic in their
vicinity using a trace charm however
throughout the series this enforcement
method was shown to be highly
inconsistent for instance when Dobby or
Harry performed magic at the dley the
ministry was quickly in formed in
contrast when members of the Order of
the Phoenix used magic in the same
location there appeared to be no
reaction from the trace ultimately the
trace charm proved highly ineffective
particularly as it wasn't able to
properly identify the person responsible
for casting the Magic in the first place
why didn't Harry contact Sirius instead
of going to the ministry throughout the
Harry Potter series Harry and his
Godfather Sirius communicate through a
variety of covert means but when Harry
becomes concerned that Sirius is in
danger he fails to employ any of them in
the Order of the Phoenix Harry
encounters a vision of Sirus being held
captive at the ministry and fearing his
friend is in danger he recklessly rushes
to his Aid as a result Harry falls into
the clutches of the Death Eaters and
Sirius ultimately loses his life however
I feel like this entire tragedy could
have been prevented if Harry had simply
used an alternative and already EST
established method of
communication you see earlier in the
series Sirius had given Harry a two-way
mirror which she and Harry's Father
James utilized during their school days
while Harry does use a fragment of the
mirror to contact Abba forth later in
the series it would have been more
advantageous if he had used it to
confirm whether or not Sirus was in
danger before acting upon his fears the
books do mention that Harry forgot about
the mirror in his haste but it does seem
quite improbable that no one would have
thought to use it at any point how old
is mcgonagal this particular plot hole
actually branches over into the
Fantastic Beast universe according to
the timelines presented in the books it
was a commonly held belief that
Professor mcgonagal was born in the year
1935 however her appearance in a scene
set at Hogwarts in 1910 depicted in the
crimes of grindal left everyone a little
bit confused mle's presumed birth year
places her in the late 1880s but her
engagement at the age of 18 to a muggle
who died in the first Wizarding War
seems to challenge this estimation at
present there is no reasonable
explanation for this
inconsistency Sirius and poly juice
potion though Sirius Black was able to
clear his name in the eyes of those
closest to him he remained unable to
prove his innocence to The Wider
Wizarding World consequently he was
confined to grimel place largely unable
to join the other Wizards in the ord's
battle against Voldemort at times his
frustration led him to break the rules
of his confinement transforming into his
dog form to visit Harry and escaped the
confines of the house however Sirius was
cautious since the ministry was aware of
his dog form and he needed to avoid
being sent back to aaban and while
transforming into his dog form was
undoubtedly a sensible precaution there
is another method that Sirius could have
explored which seems more appropriate
but poly juice potion poly juice potion
which allows you to change your physical
form is seemingly not overly complex to
create even students with minimal
training seem to be able to manage it
and has the ability to deceive any other
wizard quite easily Sirius could have
assumed the physical form of another
order member traveling around largely
unnoticed why Sirius would not have
explored this option is a mystery to me
Harry and the thestrals a thestral is a
breed of winged horse with skeletal and
reptilian features resembling sort of
evil Pegasus these horses if you could
call them that pull the carriages at
Hogwarts and are only visible to those
who have witnessed death Harry first
sees these creatures at the beginning of
his fourth year following the death of
Cedric digory however fans have pointed
out that Harry should have seen
thestrals earlier in the Goblet of Fire
after the tri was a tournament ends and
digory has already died Harry sees the
Horseless carriages theoretically he
should have been able to see the
thestrals at that time but they only
become visible to him in the next book
JK Rowling herself has addressed this
discrepancy explaining that a person
must fully internalize death in order to
see theils everyone has said to me that
Harry saw people die before he could see
the thols just to clear this up once and
for all this was not a mistake I really
thought this one through Harry did not
see his parents die he was 1y old and in
a cot at the time although you never see
that scene I wrote it and then cut it he
didn't see it he was too young to
appreciate it when you find out about
the thestrals you find that you can see
them only when you really understand
death in a broader sense when you really
know what it means someone said that
Harry saw Quirrell die but that is not
true he was unconscious when qurl died
in philosopher stone he did not know
until he came around that quirrel had
died when Voldemort left his body then
you have Cedric with Cedric Fair Point
Harry had just seen Cedric die when he
got back into the carriages to go back
to hogsmeade station I thought about
that at the end of goblet because I've
known from the word go what was drawing
the carriages from Chamber of Secrets in
which there are carriages drawn by
invisible things I have known what was
there I decided that it would be an odd
thing to do right at the end of the book
anyone who was sufff a bement knows that
there is the immediate shock but that it
takes a little while to appreciate fully
that you will never see that person
again until that had happened I did not
think that Harry could see the thestrals
that means that when he goes back he saw
these spooky things it set the tone for
Phoenix which is a much darker book
Neville and dementes another plot hole
related to Harry's memories of his past
arises when the ders appear on the
Hogwarts train While most of the
children feel cold and miserable in
their presence Harry experiences a more
intense reaction he hears someone
screaming collapses and requires
Professor lupin's assistance to drive
the dementor away it is explained that
Harry is profoundly affected because he
has witnessed true Horrors in his past
and the screaming he hears is a memory
of his mother's death this explanation
is logical but it raises the question of
why Neville who also exper experienced a
tragic event in childhood did not have a
similar reaction on the train Neville's
parents were tortured into Insanity by
the cruciatus curse when he was just 16
months old which is almost the same age
that Harry was when his parents died
moreover Neville even visited his
parents at St witnessing their
state and having knowledge of what
happened to them one would assume that
this level of horror would be enough to
affect Neville in the presence of
Dementors as well the port keep
timetable during the Quidditch World Cup
Harry and the Weasley use a port key an
old boot to reach the event Across The
Wizarding World numerous Port keys are
set up implying specific activation
times however the port key Voldemort
uses to transport Harry in the tri was a
tournament must have been Enchanted to
work only within the maze as Voldemort
couldn't possibly know when Harry would
reach the cup it raises the question of
how the port key was timed correctly
some Port Keys may have wider timing
windows but the World Cup Port Keys had
a small window to prevent Muggles from
using them the try was at cups Port key
likely had a wider window to cover the
contestants time in the Maze my point is
this the specifics behind Port keys and
their timings remains a bit of a mystery
why didn't the ministry use its truth
serum verit serum capable of compelling
truth from the Drinker is one of the
most powerful potions in The Wizarding
World but for some strange reason it's
heavily underutilized in the story this
potion had the potential to greatly
benefit the ministry of magic in
resolving a multitude of issues more
efficiently for example following the
first visiting War this truth serum
could have been used during the trials
of known Death Eaters some escaped
imprisonment by claiming to be under the
imperious curse While others like Sirus
Black were unjustly convicted the use of
veritus serum could have eliminated any
doubt I won't go in much further as I've
actually already made a much larger
breakdown of why veritus serum was used
so infrequently but if you're curious go
and check it out why didn't Sirius
Escape aaban sooner in Harry Potter and
the prison of aaban Harry learns that a
dangerous murderer Sirius Black has
escaped from aaban prison with the
intention of killing him although
sirus's motivations become clearer
towards the climax of the film One Thing
Remains unclear C why he chose to remain
imprisoned for such a long time fans of
the movies and books know that Sirius
used his animus form a large black dog
to escape he intentionally lost weight
then transformed and squeezed through
the bars of the prison however this
raises the question of why he didn't do
it sooner as transforming into his
animal form seems relatively simple
Sirius could have easily lost the weight
in a matter of weeks so why fester in
aaban for years one argument for why
Sirius would have remained in aaban is
that he would have had no way to prove
his innocence however after seeing
pettigru in the Weasley family's photo
in the newspaper he would have seen this
as an opportunity to regain his freedom
and prove his innocence prompting his
Escape why was Cho Chang at the Battle
of Hogwarts in the Goblet of Fire were
introduced to Cho Chang a fifth year
student who becomes involved with Cedric
diory and later joins Dumbledore's Army
she also develops a romantic
relationship with Harry interestingly
despite graduating from Hogwarts in
Harry Potter and the halfblood prince
Joe is still present at the school
during the Battle of Hogwarts this
raises the question of why she is still
there especially since she is seen
wearing a uniform the answer to this
plot hole sort of boils down to what
version of Harry Potter you're looking
at book or movie in the books Joe
returns to hog H warts after getting a
message on the Dumbledore's Army coin
subsequently apparating into Hog's head
and entering Hogwarts through Ariana's
portrait to join the fight in the movies
on the other hand Joe Chang is
represented as being in the same year as
Harry which is why she would have been
present for the battle and that's it for
today's video what do you think of these
plot holes do you have any you'd like to
add please leave a comment down below
also if you enjoy the content please
like the video and subscribe to the
channel until next time remember it does
not do to dwell on dreams and forget to
live